bon an mal an on arrive à la question
que se posent tous les journalistes il
s'est juste part je prends pour linceul
de sur la gueule
ce qu'on pourra voir à ce 284 tu rêvais
d'avoir des jumeaux je rêvais pas
d'avoir dit je disais je rêve d'avoir
des jumeaux bon si tu auras des enfants
pour soi des jumeaux ces deux d'un coup
sec 888 il disait ne pas vouloir
d'enfant parce que tu étais trop occupé
pour bien s'en occuper
le jour où tu en auras tu quitteras tout
ou est ce que c'est parce que tu ne veux
pas tout quitter que tu n'en fais pas
bête comme question non c'est ça se fait
pas comme ça ouais des enfants venant tu
seras laxiste avec eux non j'étais j'ai
une des questions très sévère je serai
seul verre tu pense qu'il faut les tenir
rigueur alors oui parce que sinon tu as
vu ce que ça donne j'étais venu avec
façon 21 juste un gp un seau d'eau on
n'était même pas coller je veux dire est
ce que est ce que les gosses est ce que
tes gosses si un jour tu as des enfants
est-ce qu'ils auront le droit de
regarder dorothée
sais pas si je serai encore là ouais
mais à ton habitude laisserait regarder
des cif bon si tu rencontré l'homme de
ta vie tu qui traite ou
une supposition non tu piges fait pas
tout neuf ans c'est bien de dire c'est
honnête de le dire tu prennes rencontrer
ou ce mec là parce que comme tu
travailles beaucoup et que le reste du
temps tu es chez toi ou chez ta mère tu
penses que tu vas pas dans les boîtes
qui pourrait le rencontrer ou l'homme de
ta vie
ah oui quand en vacances latin mais
j'espère encore rencontré à la tap a dit
ai dit que je n'y ai point déjà
rencontré on va envoyer des paparazzi
devant chez toi tu veux pas vieillir
seul ça te ferait peur de vieillir seul
je ne ferai pas peur tellement loin est
ce que tu es oui est ce que tu as des
chèques très sensuellement troublé par
une femme non jamais jamais une émotion
comme ça quand tu étais chez les soeurs
au parlement
je parle pas nécessaire je parles de tes
copines d'école non non jamais alors
dorothée on arrive à un dur moment
maintenant c'est les fameuses questions
cons à lola ohlala alors ça commence
simplement tu es jarretelles ou collante
ses collants bon d'accord t'es soutien
gorge ou seins nus bon ok j'ai pas
vraiment toujours trouvé amataï c'est à
dire que là tes seins nus tu veux dire
tant ce mur
est ce que tu es slip ou caleçon quel
chouette ah ouais j'ai fait ça dès
qu'elles feraient tout ce temps là oui
j'ai vu qu'elles sont sous ses atours
abelin pas qu'elles sont d'aider des
gros h un grand machin eux est-ce que tu
préfèrerais mourir et dentelle soie
machin non non
tu comprends tu vas tu dis que tu
arrives pas tu marier mais tu comprends
si tu cites suis jamais dit je n'ai pas
tu préfèrerais mourir
rayon laser bombe à neutrons ou gaz
inodore
au laser ça fait du spectacle laser
c'est dommage gaz gaz inodore t'avais
tâche france
tu pouvais continuer à tendre nos
invités de souci non c'est bien de
changer sur ça c'est bien continuez
monsieur baffe alors imagine
j'imagine que tu sois coincés dans un
ascenseur veut déjà imagine que tu sois
coincés dans un ascenseur qui préférait
être coincé avec qui
catherine lara
se marre pas muriel robin
ou marie paule belle
non non je ne sais pas choisissant une
un ascenseur c'est pas une navette
spatiale qui parle mais il revint dans
ses rangs des histoires ah ouais muriel
robin avec toi dans un ascenseur pendant
qu'en même temps tu tiendras déboires
ces ascenseurs qui risque de pâtir
alors ton julie arrive par imagine c'est
une supposition tout ça c'est des
questions fort suppositions suppositions
ton julien arrives pas tu lui demande
comment elle s'appelle premières
suppositions deuxième suppositions tu
lui fais un truc spécial pour qu'ils y
arrivent troisièmes suppositions tu te
casses en claquant la porte
à demain as tu te casses en claquant la
poche à l'apport dont j'ai pu t'en vas
nous enviera demain la question suivante
j'aimerais mettre la pause et
pas ici pas de vent pas devant tout le
monde un peu pour l eau nous voilà à pas
loin d'accord tu viens ok
oui dit ben dorothée si tu devais partir
sur une sur une île déserte
tu choisirais qui entre dechavanne de
caunes frédéric mitterrand a dû prendre
acte et je
suis obligé de dire toi non franchement
des franchement
toi ça va pas être triste c'est vrai tu
prends ma - e il va tirer une semaine ça
valait le dessertes avec moi une semaine
ces revers s'est pas loupé une bise
sur les jours prochains oui
quand même on y retourne pas laisser
tout seul on va quand même
ouais
je te dirais même pas ce que c'est bon
pour moi
je crois que c'est bon pour moi qu'un
jour j'y suis venu rouler une pelle ça
n'a pas marché mais j'ai une ouverture
c'est vous
bon on va parler business un peu ma
petite dorothée au 1 quai ce cas
d'autres l'amour l'argent 1 alors t'as
combien d'heures sur tf1 par semaine
une vingtaine une vingtaine à tu le sais
ça par contre je sais pas combien tu
gagnes mais tu sais comme un trader sur
tf1 mais avec jean luc azoulay votre
site est quand même à peu près 70 % des
émissions des moins de 12 ans pas mal
quand même
tu as vendu combien de l'album tu sais à
peu près
12 millions ouais
tu savais pas alors promis
tu sais combien tu as des acheteurs pour
dorothée magazine tucci
150000 ouais c'est qu'on mette à fait
d'entrer à bercy attend
130 mille quatre cent soixante dix mille
dangers voirie
pas mal quand même non et je suis très
bien dire pour moi je passais pas fort
est intéressant d'avoir une salle pleine
ouais enfin les chiffres intéressants
parce que tu toucherait 1 franc par
entrer cette fois déjà 170 me le font
par
ta vidéo est triple platine bien tu vois
sympa il faut que tu viennes ici pour
savoir à combien revient plus souvent
devraient travailler ensemble
alors sans compter la chine parce que
c'est quand même exceptionnel si tu es
devenu star en chine c'est pas de la
rigolade quand même donc tu es allé en
chine au départ c'était comme ça juste
pour faire un petit
des spectacles dans une petite salle à
shanghai et puis je suis retourné je
crois que la troisième fois c'est la
troisième année ne vient les quatre fois
je crois et c'est un grand coup de
foudre était à bord grande histoire
d'amour pourquoi est-ce que tu as le jeu
sur le net chinois sont fascinés par les
gens qui ont le nez un peu comme ça
entre eux régalés aussi tu crois quoi
que je pourrais y avait laissé en
mongolie au site a fait un tabac
d'immenses
succès
toutefois j'ai une théorie sur toi à
maintien c'est que ta voix et mais une
fréquence spéciale à laquelle les
enfants sont particulièrement réceptifs
est né en chine sont pas des enfants qui
viennent sont des adultes chez cap et
bep produite en chine mais ça s'est bien
goupillé meurs
tu dis que tu n'as pas autant d'argent
qu'on croit mais est ce que tu sais
combien on imagine
avec l'emploi du temps que tu as tu vas
voir un robot commenté c'est quoi le
secret de ta forme je viens tu dois être
un robot bionique pas du tout sera est
assez tant que ça ah bon tu dis ça pour
ton image est ce que c'est vrai tout je
crois qu'à un moment tu sais que je
travaillais vachement qu'un jour tu te
dis quand même pour moi l'image que
j'arrête de dire que je travaille tout
le temps je crois que je travaille
beaucoup pour moi je travaille beaucoup
quand ils le font mais quand j'ai pas
besoin je travaille bien séparées ce
trèfle m mais cette tendance à la
paresse tu as le temps de vérifier quand
on travaille tout le temps on travaille
pas tout le temps mais le week end je
travailles pas tu fais quoi quand tu
fais rien rien vraiment rien parce que
j'ai vu dans un joint tu disais que tu
fais la lessive c'est un truc pour la
wii je sais c'est vrai ouais c'est pas
dur tu me donneras machine tpu sur un
bouton et même d'afibel ça elle est
blanchie par jour des noces oui ça c'est
donc ça c'est pas pour les journalistes
ici ça va j'aime bien faire rentrer
aussi ah bon mais je voudrais bien comme
petter n'arrive pas tous les ans quand
même c'est bien dommage fatma les envies
trois pièces la lessive la vaisselle le
meilleur moment finalement ton meilleur
moment c'est pas quand tu te retrouves
chez toi avec mon chien
d'abord il s'appelle jambes le nom il
s'appelle roxana 3 501 c'est un petit
garçon gentil monsieur et c'est pas le
meilleur moment ça quand tu es tout seul
j'ai pas un meilleur moment j'ai pleins
d'hommes en tout temps
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu